welcome back everyone this is the hero
daily today i'm going to be going over
the leaks that we have so far on moon
night uh some of these are definitely
ones you've heard before but i do want
to go through them and get you ready for
that march 30th release uh let's get
started show alternates between 2003 and
2023 it will be a trippy sliding time
scale that i've heard compared to
westworld and mr robot and this is one
that we do know already uh it does want
to simultaneously explore mental health
issues wealth disparity and superhero
action mark spectre will be the mcu's
first truly flawed protagonist he will
make decisions that will shock you
currently the first episode he throws a
man off of a skyscraper to his death
despite it being disney plus they aren't
pulling any punches
again this is one that we do know
already moon knight is pushing the
limits of the pg-13 rating uh and it is
faithful to the source material for
those of you who are fans of a moon
knight already and know that he does
have disassociative identity disorder it
won't be referenced until episode 3 but
from episode 1 we will see him switching
between his different alter egos in the
initial plans for moon knight there
would be an appearance by blade and a
mention of supernatural figures that are
all over the universe and a hint of
ghost rider and just to add more mystery
to the entire series itself uh the
ending of the season we'll have mark
waking up at a mental hospital uh do
with that as you will let me know what
you guys think in the comments are you
guys excited for this one still i know
this one is definitely a lot darker than
our other series and movies that we've
seen so far in the mcu please if you
haven't already uh please subscribe i am
a small channel and i'm trying every day
to impress you enough to subscribe and
hopefully i did that today if not well
maybe tomorrow anyways thank you so much
and i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
he knew the world would not be the same
two people
laughed
a few people cried
those people were silent